so bill gates and melinda gates dude
they broke up and
honestly so love isn't real you know
yeah they were so good together man
i was just picturing with like like
stands for playing yeah
breakup note like they wouldn't ever
know like literally like if bill and
melinda aren't together
love is no hope for you anymore man
bro they were so [ __ ] good together
man
you imagine that you imagine them making
a youtube video trying to explain
yeah hi guys we're here on microsoft
teams
letting you all know that melinda and i
have decided to part ways
she's just like fr sterile from the 19
test vaccines that bill gates has come
up with
she's just like like high as god
just like trying to like come to to be
like yes
we're broken up she's going through a
little bit of a self-trial
something we've been both working on i'm
a lizard so it doesn't affect me as much
but remember you can sign up for a
vaccine using microsoft teams
[Laughter]
anyways yeah man i just i really was
laughing at all the memes to be honest
i really did just like what were they
just
just uh bill like just booking his trip
to miami with the boys
oh okay okay yeah yeah
just picturing him as like just an
absolute horn dog
billionaire horndog yeah it's white boy
summer boy
bill no bell bill
come on aren't you like 75
just pulling up yeah my dick's 48
[Laughter]
yeah bill that's still old still an old
dick
my dick is windows 10 if you know what
i'm saying
yeah yeah oh [ __ ] he could definitely
afford afford panuma
yeah bill could um imagine bill
pulling up in his big ass yacht
you know like some summer party yeah a
big ass megaphone
hello everyone i'm utilizing microsoft
teams
to let you know that it is white boy
summer
i am std free by the way
all the boats going away
bill gates the single guy
i bought the rights to that song so i
can do that now it's technically my song
boom boom boom boom
bro he's 65 really that's it
dang my guy looks way older than 65 yeah
yeah i'm sorry my guy looks like he's
been incubating
in a pickle jar
seriously just crusty what did millen
that's melinda
dude they were so good together man i
wish they did
so good together i wish they did a
youtube video i know
that looks like one doesn't it hi guys
i don't i don't even know how to start
this video
[Applause]
i'm not gonna cry i'm really not i'm a
billionaire but
um me and melinda are it's over
this i'm sorry this is like our fourth
time recording this video we tried like
four times and every time because bill
forgets where he is
hi board of directors no bill bill this
is our breakup video
oh right hi guys it's bill here and i
just want to say that
um after 40 great years
of being with melinda we've decided that
i'm [ __ ] stoked to be single
bill bill do you have a boner
you've had a boner in 10 years i'm sorry
honey i'm torqued up
[Laughter]
send you johnson and johnson strain i'm
working on
gets you hard as nails
yeah bro this is a party called
programmer bros and windows oh
nice yeah
thank you kyle thank you kyle
[Laughter]
this is my impression of bill gates in
miami
coming off of his you know inviting nine
college girls on his billion dollar
yacht right
you know i have a i have a secret
version of windows that no one's heard
about
i want to know what it is what is it
windows sex
me
[Music]
that's so bad
i know no it's windows sex me it's like
xp no i get it i get it it's also kind
of like one of those 2000 me edition do
you have any cocaine or not
yeah yeah inside window sex me there's a
lot of cocaine
you're leaving why oh no
uh you don't have to oh
no nothing i was going to say something
about a firewall in him [ __ ] without
a condom but
it wasn't really yeah
no hit it i'm scd-free you won't need
norton antivirus
i don't know why i keep picturing bill
gates like feeling the need to brag
about the fact
he doesn't have stds
you know it's been out of the game for a
while people have seds now right
you don't have to worry pat mcafee
antivirus is nowhere near this dick
nothing to worry about no viruses here
maybe a little bit of malware because
i've been spying on you
bill bill bill bell bill
i wonder who bill gates first new bae is
going to be
some like instagram model that would be
that would just be like that would be
bad
just a 20 year old yeah like bill
come on bill bill what
you you can't do that bill now
i'm gonna say his first
his first smash is going to be it's
going to be like his name
paula deen jeez
jeez that came out so fast bro
you didn't even hesitate bill why don't
you come over to my place i'll cook you
some cinnamon buns
saving funds
yo you said paula dean like it was
family feud
for paladins
did you see that family feud clip of the
guy barking at the girl the girls
did that
dude did we do did i send that clip to
the thread no i thought that was fake i
thought that was like edited together
i mean i don't care if it's faker it's
like one of the funniest clips ever
is it fake steve harvey's like isn't
that your wife right there
and then the guy's like no she's
watching at home
oh bro sorry i'm just still i'm still
stuck on
bill why don't you come over and i'll
make you some sami
i'll make you some good some good
southern corn i
i don't know if paula paula dean's like
what about laura dern
uh no no no he's not getting with laura
dern
she's too cool yeah no
damn bill and paula deen that would be
wretched
are you like looking up pictures of her
yeah i'm looking at her right now you
didn't know what she looked like
i forgot what she looked like bruh she's
like
ursula's a coke dealer
nailed it damn it she is there she is
imagining look at that smile right there
yeah she is frightening
demon you want to eat this salmon cake
yeah
oh no salmon cake no
no no why don't you dive on this fish
bill
[Laughter]
the river is always open in paula town
you never had some good old-fashioned
louisiana crawfish have you
get that hammer over there you have to
break this crustacean wide open
her pussy's like crab you gotta crack it
[Laughter]
open
oh my god
jesus [ __ ] bro oh
that's disgusting that's a power couple
yeah that is a power couple
yes the l them smashing would be awful
no don't don't put bill next to laura
man i don't want to picture laura
just i don't want to picture bill
just pleasuring him yeah i don't want to
think about that
this is about the same way i came up
with windows
xp the real one
it's just like this i was having sex
you